and there's the guy throwing into your
living room garrett cole he's a pretty
good pitcher on the season this will be
start number seven four and one record i
mean those numbers are really good and
he's in the middle of the diamond and of
course
towing the slab in the boogie down bronx
jose altuve will lead it off against
garrett cole this ball is grounded up
the middle and in the center a base hit
for altuve and the leadoff man is on for
the astros and the boos intensified
here's michael brantley the 1-2
let's see if they turn two
there's one on to first it's a double
play
so here is alex bregman three for eight
in the first two games of the series
strike three bregman down looking first
strikeout for cole lance mccullers jr on
the mound for the astros today and a lot
of his experience against the yankees
has come in the postseason and some of
his better games against them have come
in the postseason and he'll face dj le
mayhew to lead things off for new york
off the glove of mccullers bare hand out
two bay jose makes a nice defensive play
to get dj lemay who the opposing second
baseman and that'll bring up giancarlo
stanton so he's hitting 500 in the 11
game streak five homers 10 reviews
slugging at 896. crowd chanting mvp here
at the stadium well if you want a master
class on how to turn booze into mvp just
go on this type of run runs inside ball
four so a lot of lateral movement on
these two seamers from the colors
and the yankees have a one out base
runner here's aaron judge he had a rough
night last night over five with five
strikeouts that is strike three call at
the knees frozen with the slider and
mccullers picks up his first k two out
so two out at stanton still at first for
geo urchella the third baseman and he
walked him
so second walk in the inning as stanton
moves to second base and that'll bring
up gleber torres a little bit high
and another walk to load the bases
that'll bring up mike ford so the
yankees have loaded them up not that
they've done anything to deserve it
they've walked three times mike ford
needs a base hit and ford rips it caught
by guriel and the astros can breathe a
sigh of relief that was a line shot off
the bat of mike ford yankees leave them
loaded so we go to the top of the second
and here is the big lefty slugger jordan
alvarez 1-2 swing and a miss
alvarez down on strikes second strikeout
for cole went away
backhanded by torres
the stretch by ford and a one two three
inning for garrett cole we go to the
bottom of the second inning nothing
nothing here's aaron hicks owen is
ripped off the glove of the diving
goriel into right field to base hit for
hicks and the yankees have their first
hit and the yankees have the lead off
man on for their catcher kyle higashioka
strike three call on the outside corner
frozen with the heater and that is the
second strikeout for mccullers one away
the o2
swing and a miss good morning good
afternoon and good night dj le mayhew
got him on a high fastball two
strikeouts in the inning for mccullers
works around the lead-off hit
now to the bottom of the third and
here's giancarlo to lead it off 24 for
48 five almost 10 rbis in 11 games he
raised his average from 158 to 314. that
one's drilled to right center field and
deep there it goes
see ya off the back wall of the bullpen
he extends his hitting streak to 12
straight
the magic juan lives that man is
absolutely amazing one-nothing yankees
here's aaron judge here's the o2
change up got him strike three he struck
out seven times in a row now there's one
away mike ford the batter breaking ball
did he go look like he did and he did
strike three fifth strikeout for
mccullars and that'll do it for the
yankees here in the third
cole with a one-nothing lead on the
stanton homer bradley wrapped into a
double play in the first and gets
one-nothing yankees
chops slowly toward ford makes the play
steps on the bag here's bregman he
struck out his last time line to right
field coming on judge dives and makes
the play
took a hit away from bregman terrific
play judge had a run toward the foul
line leave his feet and make the grab
before it hit the grass just terrific
play and for cole just two strikeouts
and three and two third innings so two
down and here is jordan alvarez slider
and this one's hit well right field this
could be gone it's gone
you're on alvarez a jack to right field
and ties it up and what a piece air
jordan
flies once again in yankee stadium so an
infield single for hicks here's clint
frazier clint fraser really searching
almost every at bat his stance is a
little bit different high fly ball right
field tucker back on the track at the
wall see ya home run frasier a two-run
shot
downtown ghost frazier and the yankees
lead three to one
bottom of the fifth inning aaron judge
will stand in and it's a ground ball
left side diving to his left bregman up
with it throws to first and in time to
get judge bregman robbing aaron judge of
a base hit for the first out of the
inning one on one out here's the left
hand hitting michael brantley
grounded a fourth
goes the second one onto first cole
takes the throw for the double play
three six one and that'll do it in the
sixth but colors still in there who face
the bottom third of the order the payoff
pitch it's a ground ball right side to
his right altuve backhands it pops out
of his glove picks it up throws to first
in time to get the out solid six innings
out of lance a couple of home runs hurt
him but it's 3-1 yankees how about
garrett cole he has two strikeouts today
the two strikeouts through six innings
are his few strikeouts through that many
innings since
june 13th of
2017. here's alvarez
alvarez
has he done it again deep to center
field yes he has
you're nod alvarez for the second time
today against garrett cole goes deep
this one to straight away center field
we have a one-run game and correa will
be the battle strike three correa down
looking so a strong finish for cole well
you knew that a big moment was going to
find out too that he has been at the
forefront of all the vitriol from the
fans that have come through the turn
styles for these three games this is his
birthday he's been booed throughout and
now he comes up in a big moment for the
astros with runners on the corners and
one out three two and el tuve drives
this one deep to left field and sends
back frazier at the wall looking up see
you later
jose altuve
on his 31st birthday hits a home run
that probably feels as good as ending in
his career a three-run shot and gives
the astros a 5-3 lead good for you jose
and gleber torres picks up a lead-off
single well here is aaron hicks
up the middle and knocked down but
that's all they'll get now going to
third which is not covered is torres
heads up base running now he's heading
home there's nobody home he scores it's
5-4 astros heads up base running by
clever torres tucker at first base after
drawing that walk on five pitches
now it's maldonado and that is hammer
deep down the left field line ball is
sucking if it's fair it's gone and that
is a fair ball a two-run home run for
martine maldonado and the astros lead
grows it's seven to four ryan presley
out for his second inning of work gave
up a run in the eighth well here's
stanton with one on and one out
it's sharply diving stop bregman two out
two day for one
play turn ends the game
amazing double play started by the dive
by alex bregman the houston astros in
their three-game losing streak
defeating the new york yankees 7-4